joining us now with reaction is House
Minority Whip Steve Scalise of Louisiana
American Conservative Union Chairman
match slap one of our favorites New York
congressman Lee Zeldin and Fox News
contributor Charlie hurt gentlemen thank
you so much for joining you all of us
with us tonight
I want to start with you Whip Scalise I
got to tell you this does give Nancy
Pelosi more power when she tells members
of Congress you don't even need to show
up anymore you need now have proxy
voting and we can just do this without
you right yeah Jason you know the thing
is it gives Nancy Pelosi power but
imagine being a Democrat who goes back
home in a swing district you just voted
to give your voting card in Congress to
Nancy Pelosi and she doesn't represent
the values of a lot of those districts
you know you now signed on for San
Francisco values and by the way what are
you doing that why you collecting a
paycheck if you want Nancy Pelosi to be
the one to vote for you and represent
your district and you're representing a
swing state somewhere else and so this
is gonna be a tough vote for those
people to explain it's unconstitutional
first of all because a quorum under this
just this resolution they just passed 20
people on the floor 20 Democrats can
constitute a quorum of the House of
Representatives 435 people that goes
against article 1 of the Constitution
they don't seem to care about any of
that they just want to consolidate power
and spend money I mean a drunken sailor
would be offended to be compared to them
and what they did with this bill money
to illegals taxpayer funding of abortion
this is crazy but I got to ask you
congressman are does that mean that
you're gonna challenge this in court are
you going to go to court and say hey and
challenge the constitutionality of this
well if they pass any bill using these
new rules they haven't done it yet but
they are now creating this opportunity
to have 20 people on the floor to
constitute a quorum and Nancy Pelosi
literally be able to help hold the
voting cards of so many of these people
if they pass I just think it's gonna be
an interesting lesson to be challenged
it'll be challenged I that that'll be
interesting because I believe that you
would certainly have standing now
congressman Zeldin this bill that is
being voted on right now it's just on
the verge of passing three trillion
dollars
this thing is larded up with all kinds
of pork and other things how do you see
this bill over 1,800 pages three
trillion dollars this isn't a bill that
was drafted through bipartisanship
vetting debate compromise none of that
it gives a stimulus checks to people who
are legally in our country massive
prison release legalizes throughout
america ballot harvesting it outlaws
voter ID it extends unemployment in a
way that's going to keep people out of
work for almost another year I'll add
another one to that it provides more
money to state local governments in the
hundreds of billions beyond what our
local governments are even asking for so
speaker Pelosi chose this hyper partisan
path to nowhere rather than pursuing the
alternative which was working with
President Trump working with
congressional Republicans and trying to
negotiate a compromise this is something
to appease her left flank now this is
one though that turns off most of
America and she's going to end up with a
bill that's dead on arrival in the
Senate and not going anywhere it was a
strategic failure on her part on
multiple levels on the process and the
substance this is a waste of everyone's
time and it's certainly a waste of a
whole lot of tax dollars especially with
all those liberal fantasy items totally
unrelated to coronavirus response I mean
Matt if you spend a million dollars a
day every day would take you almost
three thousand years to get to one
trillion and this bill is three trillion
dollars that's $10,000 per person in the
United States of America why not just
give them $10,000 each thanks math
thanks for doing the math for me Jason
because it's staggering and we already
did three trillion dollars so what I
think Republicans are saying which is
rational is let's let all of the money
we've already spent like drunken sailors
because the government shut down
American businesses let's set that
capitalized in the system and Jason this
is the critical point which is more
bridges and more stimulus is not what
the American economy nor its people need
they need to be legally allowed to go
back to work they need to be able to
open up their shops if you're a
mom-and-pop you should be able to be
open just like the big box
retailers are able to be open we have
this indiscriminate silly rules out
there by mostly blue state governors and
it needs to end no business can survive
if it can't make a product nor transact
with customers it's simply that clear
now Charlie the Democrats have been
trying to say oh we just need to work
together we got to find something that's
bipartisan but Nancy Pelosi didn't do
any of that I mean they say one thing do
something that's totally opposite how in
the world did they go back to the
American people and say hey we're the
adults in the room we're the ones that
will work together and get things done
when they put this monstrosity in front
of the Congress and then vote to say hey
we don't even need to come back into
session it's incredible this should be a
real wake-up call because if anybody
doubts what is at stake in this election
coming up this is what's at stake this
is what these people will do if they
can't control of the if they hold
control the house they get control of
the Senate and Lord forbid they get
control of the White House this is the
kind of insanity that that you're going
to be looking at and of course obviously
the particulars are just astonishing
the stops to illegal aliens all of that
stuff is absolutely just absolutely
reprehensible but but let's step back
for a minute let's say how in the world
does piling three trillion dollars in
additional debt on hardworking Americans
how does that help them recover from
this from this pandemic and recover from
shutting down the economy and and and we
should look back you know Minh where we
would be right now Jason if we hadn't
already piled up 20 trillion dollars of
debt on hard-working American taxpayers
but that's all these people in this
aisle do they want to pile more and more
on there and and with it comes just a
mountains of regulations that throttle
American ingenuity and Industry so and
work that that destroys Americans a
congressman Scalise you're in leadership
there Nancy Pelosi and what she's done
is signaled also in the
bill that the House of Representatives
may not come back into session until
July 21st I mean why do members of
Congress even get paid if they don't
have to go to work
postal workers go to work truckers are
gonna go to work health care workers are
gonna work but Nancy Pelosi saying no
need to show up anymore yeah can you
imagine that even the United States
Senate is going to work and there is no
reason we were here today voting you
know there were about twenty four
members who couldn't make it in out of
435 and so to suggest that it's
complicated to get here is just fallacy
so why she did this it's about a power
grab it surely has nothing to do with
health and safety because as you
mentioned you know we've got our
frontline workers back at home in our
hospitals or grocery stores now in
Louisiana today we just started opening
up so you can go into a restaurant today
at 25 percent capacity we could finally
go back into places of worship and yet
she's gonna say that she doesn't want
Congress to be meeting in Washington
debating bills she just would rather
just take your proxy vote and hold on to
it so that she can vote for you I'll
tell you this and of course Jason you
you would have never done this either
Nancy Pelosi is not gonna get my vote
she surely would not have gotten yours
but for any of those folks that voted
for this bill today how did they go back
home and explain today they voted to
allow Nancy Pelosi to vote for them so
that they don't have to go to work
anymore well then why don't they just
resign their seat and send somebody up
here who wants to come and fight for
restoring the American dream up here in
Washington thank you so much congressman
Zeldin last word we've got 15 seconds if
there's a member of House leadership of
viewing the House of Representatives is
non-essential that house leadership
members should step aside if there's any
member of the House who views themselves
as non-essential they should step aside
we should be here we shouldn't be AWOL
we shouldn't be going home right now
there's important work to do for the
American people for our economy for
businesses for the workers and now
everyone's leaving and as you pointed
out it might be for a long time until we
come back unbelievable thank you
gentlemen for joining us tonight we
really do appreciate it